nosotros en el último vídeo tomamos la
serie de mclaren de la función
exponencial verdad la representación en
serie de la x ahora vamos a hacerlo con
otro par de funciones y vamos a ver cómo
todo va encajando como un rompecabezas
gigante así que hagamos una serie de
mclaren con nuestra función coseno de x
coseno dx que ya es bastante conocida
ahora calculemos las derivadas verdad la
primera derivada de f pues es menos seno
de x verdad ahora calculemos la segunda
derivada la segunda derivada pues es
menos la derivada de seno de x y la
derivada de s 9 x es coseno x por lo
tanto me queda menos coseno de x cuál
será la tercera derivada la tercera
derivada de f pues va a ser menos la
derivada de coseno de x la derivada de
coseno de x es menos seno y con el menos
anterior nos queda seno de x finalmente
vamos a ver que la cuarta derivada de f
pues es la derivada de seno que es
coseno de x y ya regresamos a la función
original verdad esto nos va a mantener
repitiendo el patrón porque por ejemplo
la quinta derivada de f va a ser la
derivada de coseno que desde la función
original y esto va a ser menos seno de x
esto va a ser menos seno de x así que
espero que ya hayas visto el patrón
vamos a hacer ahora la representación de
la serie de mclaren que es un ejemplo
particular de las series de taylor
qué pasa cuando evaluamos estos en 0
déjenme cambiar de color para evitar la
monotonía entonces
efe evaluada en 0 es coseno de cero y
coseno de cero es uno ahora la derivada
de f evaluada en cero es seno de cero o
bueno menos seno de cero pero seno en
cero es cero así que tenemos que esto
vale cero la segunda derivada de
evaluada en cero es menos coseno de cero
pero con seno de cero es 1 y por lo
tanto me queda menos 1
la tercera derivada evaluada en cero
es seno evaluada en cero que es cero y
la cuarta derivada de f evaluada en cero
pues es igual que la función original
así que vale 1 ya nada más para terminar
la quinta derivada de evaluada en cero
pues es cero así que yo espero que ya
hayas observado cuál es el patrón que
emerge veamos cuál es este patrón miren
esto es 10 menos 10 10 menos uno y así
vamos alternando el uno el cero con el
menos uno el cero el 10 menos uno en fin
el cero por cada 0 anteriormente siempre
va a haber uno positivo luego uno
negativo luego va a seguir uno positivo
y uno negativo verdad alternando los en
el cero ahora vamos a ver cómo la
representación en la serie de mclaren
porque lo que hemos podido comprobar o
bueno espero que me lo creas es que esta
serie la serie de mclaren va a converger
en todo el dominio de la función solo
créanmelo ya tendremos las herramientas
para poder
llevar a cabo este este resultado pero
bueno cuando tomamos esta serie o estas
suma infinita esencialmente lo que
estamos creando es una función que sea
igual que la función original en el
punto y que sea igual en su derivada en
su segunda derivada y en su enésima
derivada así que intuitivamente parece
que si una función tiene todas estas
propiedades iguales en algún punto pues
en realidad estas funciones van a ser
iguales entre sí yo no he demostrado
nada insisto sabemos que la
representación es una suma desde cero
hasta infinito y de las enésimas
derivadas verdad evaluado las evaluadas
en cero y esto habrá que multiplicarlo
por x a la n porque estamos tomando un
caso particular de las series de taylor
que es la serie de mclaren así que falta
multiplicar por x a la n y dividir entre
factorial esto lo estamos haciendo ya lo
hicimos para
a la x lo estamos haciendo para coseno
de x y solo nos va a faltar para hacer
de x para que vean cuál es la magia de
esto así que esta función coseno se
convierte en esta serie bueno
fx va a ser igual entonces
qué pasa cuando n vale cero cuando n
vale cero pues la derivada de su no
perdón la función evaluada es uno y
luego x a la cero entre cero factorial
nos queda uno lo cuando en es vale uno
pues es cero porque la derivada la
primera derivada en cero vale cero
cuando n vale dos tenemos menos uno que
es la segunda derivada evaluada en cero
por equis a la 2 sobre 2 factoriales
cuando n vale 3
ahora tenemos que la tercera derivada de
evaluada en cero vale cero así que
tendremos cero por x al cubo
sobre 3 factorial cuando n vale 4
tendremos que la función la cuarta
derivada en 0 vale 1 vale 1 y hay que
multiplicar por x a la 4 sobre 4
factorial
muy bien vamos a ver si podemos
reescribir esto un poco mejor
aquí vamos a poner el quinto que es cero
por equis a la 5 entre cinco factorial y
nos seguimos ahora vamos a limpiar esto
de acá arriba vamos a limpiarlo así que
esto será igual a
esta cosa de x va a ser igual a 10 lo
quitamos y tenemos menos x cuadrada
entre 2 el 0 lo quitamos perdón entre 2
factorial verdad quitamos el 0 y luego
sumamos x a la 4 sobre 4 factorial
sala 4 sobre 4 factorial quitamos el 0 y
ahora vamos a tener que alternar el
signo verdad porque teníamos 10 menos 10
en este caso sería menos x a la 6 entre
6 factorial y así podríamos seguir nos
verdad entonces qué es lo que hemos
conseguido que podamos expresar por
ejemplo el siguiente término es x a la 8
x a la 8 sobre 8 factorial y luego
restaríamos x a la 10 sobre 10 factorial
y así nos podríamos seguir hasta el
infinito ahora
así tenemos una situación donde podemos
reescribir coseno de x coseno de x como
una suma y déjenme ponerlo en la
anotación de esta sigma la suma digamos
esta serie de mclaren en relé en
realidad converge es decir la serie es
igual a la a la función kosen esperemos
algún día tengamos esas herramientas
para demostrar que así es pero bueno
mientras esta suma va desde cero hasta
infinito y que ocurre en realidad
estamos sumando todas las potencias de x
que son pares así que esto lo estamos
elevando a la 2 n y luego hay que
dividir entre 2 n factorial correcto así
está con esta con esta fórmula estamos
garantizando todos los términos que
teníamos anteriormente ahora lo que
estamos haciendo es también intercambiar
el signo de estos elementos ahora qué es
lo que necesitamos vamos a tener que
multiplicar por menos 1 algún exponente
para que vaya cambiando
del siglo así que digamos que lo podemos
poner como un -1
vamos a multiplicar menos 1 por n 1
vamos a ver si esto funciona cuando
cuando n 0 vamos a hacer una tabulación
cuando n es 0 -1 a la n 1 tendremos que
es menos 1 a la 1 que nos queda negativo
no no no no no entonces entonces no es
así porque cuando vale 0 yo quiero que
sea positivo y cuando vale 1 que oficia
negativo así que hay que quitarle este
mazón exacto sí porque así cuando n vale
0 nos queda menos 1 a la 0 que es uno
cuando n vale 1 nos queda menos 1 y que
justo es la alternancia de los signos
que quiero verifiquemos esto por ejemplo
cuando en es igual a cero tenemos x a la
0 entre 0 factorial muy bien y eso es 1
y menos 1 a la 0 es 1 así que estamos en
lo correcto cuando en es igual a 1
tenemos x a la 2 sobre 2 factorial que
es 2 y tener
- 1 a la 1 que es menos 1 entonces
cuando n vale dos tenemos x a la 4 entre
4 factorial x menos 1 a la 4 perdón a la
2 y bueno todo va funcionando muy bien
así que esta es otra forma de
representar coseno de xy que espero se
esté volviendo interesante para ti ya
que esta representación es muy similar a
la que obtuvimos para la función era la
x cuál es la diferencia bueno en primera
sólo nos tomamos los exponentes pares
pero además vamos alternando el signo
así que en el próximo vídeo haremos la
de seno de x y trataremos de redondear